Hãy bỏa sống dầu dưới sợi râng và yên văn đang dự biến thức tạp khi ngày càng
con nhiều lực lượng bên ngoài tuyên bố tham chiến. Tối mấy thằng sau của văn án ninh
của sợi sợi râng ra gí hà lý đi tuyên bố. Nếu này sẽ tụt tấn công vào lãnh
thổ yên văn, cho đến thi phá hội được cơ sợi hạp nghiên phó đầu, một trong những chung tâm
làm dạo, uống rân đi kiên, cố nhất của tế yên văn, năm sau gần chim miếng mết giới làm đất.
Giới chức yên sợi râng trong rằng chim miếng mới sợ lụ rãi bong có thể xuyên phá phô đầu.
Từ đó, chứ thấy nỗ lực của thế nào vi nhằm kéo Washington chực kết tham chiến.
Một số quần tiên từ chuyên thông phân tay cho biết, yên sợi râng đăng tìm cách bận động hàng hàng,
để miếng chấp hận sự dụng bố khi chỉ lực.
Trong khi đó lực lượng hồ trí tại giây main hông qua khẩn định, xa hố trở i ràn trống hại yên sợi râng.
Nếu này đã phóng tư lượng đảng bỏ yên sợi râng từ ngày me lăn thằng sau,
và tuyên bộ đăng phối hợp yên ràn trong cái chiến dịch quần sợ.
Đây là lần đầu tiên hầu trí tấn công visoran,
kể được khi các thằng visoran yên ràn bụng phá.
Cũng lúc lãng đạo nhiều nước của vực như thủ nhé ki cà ta và uài đã lên tiếng phản đối láo thành chiến sợ.
Tư gọi các biên ngừng bắn và đến nghĩ hội đồng bá liên của khẩn cấp càng thiệp,
để nghen chạm khủng hòa ngàn dòng.